this morning we want to introduce you to
a north carolina woman who is bringing
together two of her passions horses and
reading to help bridge the literacy gap
among children and it's a significant
gap a national study found that only 35
percent
of fourth graders read at or above grade
level they're not considered proficient
vladiece now shows us the cowgirl
who's trying to change that by
trailblazing new ways to get kids
engaged
have you ever seen a horse before thank
you so much
we'll bring you some more books thank
you
every month caitlyn gooch shares a
little piece of her family farm with
young north carolinians
the real life cowgirl takes a horse and
a trailer full of books from the 89-acre
land of her childhood
and leads them towards one goal
inspiring kids to read
i noticed that the literacy rates in our
country need
some improvement so with volunteering
with children
in daycare centers and after school
programs kids
always love to see pictures and videos
of the horses and they would beg their
parents to come out to my house
that experience inspired caitlyn to
combine her lifelong love of reading
and horses i'm very blessed to have all
of these amazing horses this amazing
barn and i just want to share it with
children
and why not use that energy that they
have when they see the horses to get
them
excited about reading for three years
she poured that excitement into saddle
up and read
a non-profit that encourages kids to
read while interacting with horses
i'll take a horse in the horse trailer
and it's full of books
and i'll set up and i'll walk the horse
around until kids come outside
um because who doesn't notice a horse
walking around the neighborhood
their mouths just drop wide open and
sometimes kids go like this because
they're just so excited they don't know
what to do
saddle up and read is gaining national
attention
including a shout out from oprah winfrey
on twitter
kaitlyn's small north carolina community
has already taken notice
she goes above and beyond by helping
kids learn how to read in a unique way
and every time she comes anywhere
it's a flock of people that want to just
come and
and be around her and just experience
reading for the first time kaitlyn has
the patience to to
teach the writing to teach kids to read
to take the time with them
kaitlyn's parents say her passion has
always shone through
even as a little girl she's always had a
heart for animals
a heart for children she just has that
sparkle in her eye when she's around
them and this cowgirl wants to share
that love with a diverse generation of
kids
when i was younger people could not
believe that i had horses because i am
black so i'm doing my very best to get
out there and show other kids
of color is that this is very possible
for them and it's really disheartening
to hear some of their stories because
they're at these barns where they want
to feel welcome and they feel like
you know all eyes are on them because
they are black what do you think
is the magic behind the combination of
the horses
and reading horses bring this
magic that's like they can't talk
for one so if a child does mess
up while they're reading or while
they're learning something new a horse
isn't going to say anything
they're really non-judgmental caitlyn is
breaking down barriers
and building up young readers and riders
my daughter is so interested in horses
so this could be a start for her with
her
little horse journey and just inspiring
us to give back and donate to our
communities
caitlyn dreams to one day open a brick
and mortar store for saddle up and read
she says she's already raised nearly
thirty thousand dollars from people
around the country who want to help what
a great story
uh wonderful what a great person yeah
katelyn i mean
yeah the message that she's sending and
it's so interesting because i would have
never thought to put these two together
yes but this is such a critical moment
for kids when they're reading and it's
so great it's such a great way to
inspire them
it says something again vlad about
exposure exposure exposing people to
things that they don't normally get to
see
exactly right exactly right all right
vlad thanks you're watching cbs this
morning we will be right back stay with
us